[Music]
i wanted a crib close to the stadium
it's the bay rent's ridiculous so i got
some um
roommates
but this
this isn't what i signed up for i say
either
either
these guys
are not well
yummy eddie said my life wouldn't be in
danger i woke up this morning with a
tendril wrapped around my neck
not cool visiting chew tire in the
living room what's that about
these guys just don't even like each
other that was abusive which is bad
because they share a body venom's got no
chill you are a loser
yeah some of us are trying to sleep so
sick i don't know how to tell eddie it's
not working without triggering them
i respect that aggression on a football
field but not in my living room that's
the third time this week dude not cool
then on let there be carnage exclusively
in movie theaters october first
lady
we should be out there snacking on bad
guys
i am a predator
i need to be free you have got to get
control of your aggression
we will get hauled off into area 51.
live in my body you live by my
walls i'm sorry i don't know what came
over me please let me fix it so i can
fix it again
you are a loser
eddie brock
i want to give you my story
people love serial killers
jesus why me
that's mine
it's yours and what's yours
is mine
i have tasted blood before and that is
not it
i ever wanted in this world
is carnage
i'm not a crazy man
real vengeful
i promise oh yeah
betty
you feel like home to me
like family
oh wow you could just say i'm happy for
you that was going to be us hey i'm
happy for you
no
god i'm so sorry i'm sorry just doing
some serious couples counseling
[Music]
you